you ready yes sir
the toureg takoba
my name is Justin mavity I'm 36 years
old I'm from Glasgow Montana
growing up I've always loved knives
swords and I watched Forge and fire you
see it and you're like I think I could
maybe do that
the Tacoma is a type of broadsword that
has been used by the nomadic Torrid
people of North Africa since the 14th
century
this double-edged lightweight blade was
carried for self-defense on Long
Journeys designed to deliver lethal
slashes and stabs against a rival
Warrior
due to the torg's aversion to iron there
is no exposed steel or iron on the hilt
of the sword so it cannot touch the
user's hand measuring more than a meter
long this deadly weapon was seen as a
symbol of wealth some members of the
Tacoma Clan still carry this weapon
today
[Music]
Attila the Huns sword of Mars my name is
Dan Strang I am 18 years old I started
bladesmithing when I was 13 and I really
started getting serious a couple years
ago I'm definitely the youngest one here
but I love being underestimated it's one
of my favorite things known as The
Scourge you got it till of the Hun was
one of the most feared conquerors in
history the leader of the hunnic Empire
his group of nomadic tribes wreaked
havoc across Europe during the 5th
Century though he was once a great Ally
to them he played Roman territories
sacking major cities like Constantinople
Legend states that Attila was given the
sword of Mars by a herdsmen fulfilling a
prophecy and a direct sign from the
Roman war god Mars of his Divine rule
the Lethal Weapon featured a curved
handle with a spear Point tip that gave
it exceptional control allowing for
accurate and brutal thrust after
attila's death in the year 453 the
hunting Empire quickly dissolved however
the story of attila's many conquests
still live on through the television
miniseries Attila
I have to make a Keurig ketoba I don't
even I'm not even sure how to pronounce
it hopefully I would like to get the
whole thing forged out today and
possibly ready for heat treat in the
morning looking good it's coming along I
got the blade where I want it I'm half
an inch over I'm happy with that it'll
be good yesterday I got my blade heat
treated here we go move on to the pommel
now I'm going to try to key out the
bottom of this so that fits straight and
then I'll just have like a pommel nut
that goes on top and holds everything
together whether or not it works we'll
see so I got my handle all together I
have the handle all epoxied everything's
good the nuts tight guards on these
tacopas they have stars and all other
types of geometric shapes and I had hat
pins that I'd put in some of my knives
definitely not a cowboy but my brother
passed away 10 years ago and he was so I
think I'll throw this in there for him
start to dremel them out to kind of
recess them into the handle not bad
fairly happy with it I am worried about
the Tang I do wish I would have made the
Tang a little bit thicker but I mean
it's out of my hands now
it's going to be chopping up this old
muscle car to get the leaf springs out
and that's gonna be the steel for my
sword I love working with that sort of
stuff
there's my Steel
so my game plan for today is basically
get the blade rough forged out and maybe
even ground a little bit if I had enough
time
I don't have a power hammer or a press
this is my power hammer this one's for
the money there's a lot of concerns when
you make a blade this long because if
you don't have it even and flat that
gives it more of a chance to warp in the
quench
I pull it out of the oil the Blade's got
a slight warp in it but it's hard now
I'm gonna start work on my handle which
is going to be made out of this little
dolphin that I got from a thrift store I
like to find a use for everything
I want to get the Tang burned in all the
way you see how it's not smoking it
means the woods not touching any part
that's hot I couldn't get the Tang hot
enough to burn in so the only thing
keeping me from going all the way up
is the width here so I gotta stick it in
the drill press and then drill out a
little bit
I fit the handle and epoxy it in once
it's on there it's permanent
I can't go back
this is insanely nerve-wracking
if my FIT up is loose whatsoever I could
go home
welcome to the Keel test
your directobus look beautiful but the
kind of beauty I'm looking for is the
lethal kind I'm going to take your
weapon deliver some lethal blows in this
ballistics dummy dust in the up first
ready yes sir let's do this
all right
[Applause]
doesn't suck about your weapon here
first up your handle Construction
I like the avoid feel of this the flare
you have there in your pommel actually
gives great retention for this your tip
is sharp enough to penetrate your edges
are sharp when you're cutting out and
you can wheel this
to do that kind of damage on this
Public's dummy overall sir a weapon like
this
it will kill awesome
all right Dan it is your turn you ready
oh yeah let's do this I was hoping the
kill test would be a dummy I know Heads
Will Roll
all right dance talk about your weapon
here I love the balance of your blade
when I go forward it's not hard to pull
back to go in again for another kill now
you're handled construction it's curved
enough to where it doesn't want to fly
out of my hands it's got a good grip and
control for this your Edge allows for
very deep cuts into the abdomen right
there the only issue we have is that
your tip picked up a Bend when it's
chopped into the spine
but your weapon sir will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our desert well chop
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I will be
chopping into our well house as well as
the well Dustin you're on Deck you ready
yes so
okay
[Music]
all right
we were doing so well for a moment there
what actually happened was
with insetting your blade down into this
piece of wood
any of that leverage was just too much
for the wood itself and it popped it
loose your Tang is a little bit small
but what I do like to see is that your
blade actually held it beautifully I
mean your grain structure looks fine
this is an absolutely brutal test it's
very well done thank you all right
gentlemen it's time for the strength
test now attila's armies were basically
one large Cavalry and through his
military campaigns he revolutionized the
use of horse in military conflicts so to
test the strength and durability of your
blades I'll be chopping into these horse
skulls
all right Dan are you ready no but let's
do it everybody says that
all right
[Music]
at the car
okay so before we get to the obvious I
really like the design of your blade
it's got a great weight to it had a
really good feel in my hand the balance
was really nice
see all that space around your tang with
that room for that blade to move inside
the guard it could just create so much
stress that it cut loose right there at
the corner if it were all tight it
wouldn't be any stress there's no
discoloration here so it's not that
there were it was a crack here before
your grain structure looks fine it was a
well-designed piece but obvious law
foreign
forged in fire war of weapons